for more information on tutoring
personalized video solutions or how to
support move university and the
production of more videos check out moof
university comm thank you and enjoy okay
so in this video I want to kind of just
give a summary of what's going on as far
as amino acid metabolism in the liver
goes up to the top left here we've got
amino acids that have come from the
digestion of dietary proteins and before
we can actually oxidize them for energy
we have to remove their amino groups and
turn them into their alpha-keto acid
counterparts and that happens via
transamination catalyzed by amino
transferase or transaminases and of
course that requires starting with alpha
ketoglutarate and the amino group ends
up being attached to alpha cute little
ray and collecting on glutamate and so
once we have these alpha keto acids we
can oxidize them for energy and I am NOT
going to talk about that in this video
series I'm gonna talk about more about
the pathways of the oxidation of those
amino acids and their alpha-keto acid
counterparts in another series I won't
really talk about that here the point
here though is just sort of the overview
you'll notice that a bunch of arrows in
the pointing at this glutamate here and
we'll see why in just a second list
where the kuda mates are coming from
from elsewhere so up here to the top
right we've got another transamination
reaction in the alanine aminotransferase
reaction of course the amino group
attaching to this alpha keto glued right
to produce glutamate is coming from
alanine and that alanine of course is
coming from the muscle tissue from the
muscle tissue and that's an amino
transferase catalyzing that specifically
alanine aminotransferase the pyruvate
that results from that can of course in
the liver go through gluconeogenesis to
produce glucose and that can be sent
back to the blood in the glucose alanine
cycle so I didn't actually write that
here but I'll write it the glucose
alanine cycle okay to send that glucose
back into the muscle cells another
another and of course the product of
that trends transamination reaction we
get that glutamate there we also get
glutamate from hydrolyzing the a my
nitrogen off of
glutamine via the GU Tammany's reaction
and that glutamine is coming from a
bunch of extra hepatic tissues which of
course are just tissues other than the
liver so we're gonna hydrolyze off that
a my nitrogen and that'll be freed up as
an ammonium and and then glutamate now
of course that glutamate is basically
carrying that nitrogen and so oxidative
deamination nad or nad plus or nadp+
glutamate dehydrogenase reaction gives
us some nadh or NADPH and that free
ammonium ion which of course can be
detoxified in the areia cycle to give
urea which can be safely excreted okay
so that's kind of what's going on here a
bunch of nitrogen is collecting here and
being freed up here to be detoxified and
this is all really to get these amino
acids into their alpha keto acids which
of course can be oxidized for energy and
again we'll see that in a different
series of videos anyway I hope that
video was helpful to kind of put this
all together in one big picture thanks
for watching if you found that video
helpful don't forget to like comment
subscribe and share with friends thank
you and happy studying